have they done the haunting of sly manor
yet where they put it
oh goodness no but they did do the
haunting of milhouse so i think that you
should follow that up
with the meme it's meme time
how's it going reject nation g and j
here today we are going to talk about
the follow-ups haunting of hill house
q a review style basically where we take
the questions from you guys that we put
on our community page and patreon post
you guys are basically guiding the
review you're driving the review so you
guys are
involved with us as well engagement with
the audience
it's called the haunting oblige manner
by the way i haven't mentioned that
yet but let's just swing into
action here so our first question that
we got comes from horror and gamer
and he just says i feel like this is a
good opener for a review like this
out of ten zero out of ten i
personally think i would probably rate
this as a quick summary review
uh non-spoilers right now i would say
probably somewhere between 8.5 to a nine
out of ten for me i rank it pretty high
i ended up
loving it the first four episodes i was
like i like it
the the the some of the scary stuff
feels a little bit
tacked on or forced like it didn't seem
interested in it but then
by the time i got to episode five
everything started clicking a lot better
for me
the scary and intention moments started
feeling a lot more
natural they weren't like overly
abundant by the end of the story i was
very much
moved i thought it was rather
beautifully told
and i love the performances the
direction i don't find
as strong as haunting of hill house
necessarily but it is a very different
show
than the first season overall yeah i
would probably give it like 8.5 to 9. i
think it's wonderfully crafted and
overall haunting and beautiful yeah i
think in terms of number rating i'm
probably right there alongside you this
is um
you know it's fresh in my mind so part
of me wonders if it's just the sheen of
a new season
but i did feel a lot of differences from
the first season that i do
think are qualities that this season has
and yeah while
some of the more overt horror elements
are dialed back
a bit i thought it was incredibly well
directed performed written
and yeah it made up for i guess
if you want to call it a lack of you
know overt scares with things that were
surreal and unsettling and twisted and
and
you know it's tough to i think follow up
such an involved character study gothic
ghost story with another involved
character study gothic ghost story
that manages to feel different and like
its own thing
you know and uh and is still akin in the
right ways and i thought this really
nailed that i thought they changed the
format
enough to make it kind of neat and
interesting again from the first season
which had a really specific format just
really gracefully told the story
so i didn't mind it all that the horror
was a little dialed back this is the
most john and i have talked about the
show together yep
yeah yeah i'm actually getting john's
actual opinion here we haven't discussed
this yeah thanks for the question horror
gamer much appreciated and then
i chose this for number two originally i
wanted to save a question like this
for last uh but i actually think this
seems to be one of the main discussions
that either
falls under like the why people might be
disappointed category
or why people might not be as uh
responsive to this season
as they were with haunting of hill house
so bradley but so over at patreon asked
how would you guys compare the scares
of bly manor to those of hill house
haunting hill house has one of the most
memorable jump scares i've ever
experienced in my entire
life that was i believe the penultimate
episode when
uh what's the actress's name victoria
pedretti
as a ghost comes out when the two other
sisters are arguing
and there's not a single scare here that
comes near the level
of that and i'll also add that there's
no reveal or shock moment
in this season that compares to the
reveal of the bet neck lady
in haunting of hill house you know
there's a couple of spooky moments i
felt
anything with the lady of the lake
before we got her backstory
those were some of the scariest moments
to me as a matter of fact kind of a
reversal moment
would have to be the third to last
episode when it ends where
victoria is trying to get um or not
danny will call the character and danny
is trying to get flora out of the house
and she turns and the lady of the lake's
there
grabs her by the throat and just starts
trying like that was actually a really
scary moment to me and also
when uh you're looking at
the lady of the lakes backstory and i
thought it was a really clever one where
her sister finds the dress yeah and then
her hands pop out
that that i think was the one that
bordered for me
on uh like the memorable jump scare of
the
of the season because yeah it's in such
a
legitimized character moment that it
felt
very well earned but also you know it
comes out of nowhere and it makes you
jump
but at the same time though i as you
asked this quest because i like i got
the questions but i haven't written
anything down or made any notes so
as we're doing this is a very on the fly
kind of i'm wearing a flasher it's a
very on-the-fly
response and i still had to find myself
wracking my brain
as i was anne's reading your question
out loud whereas haunting of hill house
i'm like nah i still remember that
that's like a no-brainer to me
yeah um to kind of piggyback off of your
question a little bit
more this is such a different season and
and i feel like the uh penultimate
episode where you get the lady of the
lake story
i think you know tonally especially when
you're gonna dive into that backstory i
i felt like they were trying to strike a
mood and tone
where every episode could feel part of
the same
season part of the same show especially
if you're gonna do something like that
of the lady of the lake
and this is definitely more of a gothic
romance
and it's a ghost star it's a ghost story
in a gothic romance at the same time
but it's definitely nowhere near as
scary like the scares feel kind of
limited to me
it's in the in the first four episodes
it started feeling like ah crap it's
starting to feel like a netflix show
with the scares in the sense of
the scary thing happens in the last five
minutes
and then we have a cliffhanger so you
can watch the next episode and sometimes
the ones that were sprinkled in within
the
then this is really just the first four
episodes where i was feeling this
sometimes some of the scary stuff
sprinkled in
throughout the first four especially
with danny being haunted by
eddie uh the kevin from sin city
the anime doom glasses or whatever that
is yeah
that was like that's not very there's
something about it i started to get the
impression that the show's not
interested in being scary
but they have to have some scares i got
the sense that it wasn't necessarily a
show's bread and butter especially in
this season to do
those very kind of popular
conjuring-esque i feel like the
conjuring has had a certain level of
influence where
anything ghostly and gothic has to have
a certain level of these jump scares
yeah i mean
as a lot of people and we have said i
think blind manor definitely
is less overtly scary than hill house i
mean hill house
there's still ghosts peppered all around
in the background and stuff of blind
matter but hill house seemed to want to
torment you a little bit more with those
and was also playing with kids who are
frightened of these beings that are
you know not necessarily the same as
here is a specific person who lived in
our house
especially when her boyfriend her fiance
steps out of the car and gets hit by the
horror movie truck
the horror movie garbage truck that
comes out of nowhere like that was a
moment where i was kind of taken out by
the jump scare because
it's gonna go no no
i mean like i felt for the scene
certainly but it was distracted by how
they tried to make the glasses look like
the ghost
yeah you know when the trucks coming on
or like see
and that was the thing is that in those
particular moments and not always but
that's a good example of one where the
jump scare started to teeter into a
place where i could also
just really feel all the effects and
filmmaking that went into this
set piece and then it stopped feeling
like a chilling presence that happened
to have been there or some kind of
really truly random event
well it seemed to have the mike flanagan
stamp throughout even though he didn't
direct and write every episode but i
think what was missing more than
anything or the presence that i think
was
not really carried over as strongly
as the first season was the
cinematography
and and i think that guy's just too busy
directing sequels to all the boys i've
loved it or something
yeah i think that's what he's doing
right i haven't looked at him sure
i'm pretty sure if my answers me
correctly he's got those noah centennial
fish to fry or whoever whoever's in
those movies when comparing it to hill
house you have
similar things like everything you
listed and
they do have a haunted house and they
they deal
with you know themes of grief primarily
and that's what the ghosts really
represent and the haunting to me because
to me even the haunting hill house is
not that scary it's definitely scarier
than this yeah this one is more about
like the haunting from
you know within the soul yeah well yeah
like that approach it
like while it's a different kind of
scary it's you know it it leans more
into the psychological angle yeah
there's a lot of ghosts but there's
something about it feels more
that's that's what it is it feels a
little more fairy tale in this season
yeah and i think there is
a certain difference in quality where
that i do appreciate actually i
appreciate this about blind manor is
instead of going
bigger like doing a conjuring too and
putting even more craziness inside i
think
toning it down and focusing it a little
more inward
or at least on a smaller spectrum of
characters helps because
i think this season is more focused on
chilling you getting under your skin
and really kind of planting all these
icky little details that are going to
get unwound later and like
it's funny because it has a lot of
devices the first season has it's
jumping back and forth in time
and it's revealing information through
flashbacks at very strategic points
but the first caesar or i should say
hill house felt like you know a gothic
family saga family drama and every
episode
has a different character as its sole
focus and this one does in its own way
as well but there's a lot more crossover
whereas i felt like in hill house you
got
this character's episode and here's all
the scary [ __ ] that happened to them
and then this character's episode all
the scary [ __ ] that happened to them and
even though it is
shared there's a lot more individuals
stuff in the first season whereas this
felt like
a bunch of people stuck in this one
place oh yeah i mean this this was about
the souls
trapped at bly manor because of the lady
of the lakes
anger or and whatever right
just unwillingness to let go so yeah
where's hill houses
you know every like you said every
family member this is not everyone here
is blood related
it's more about like covering the ghosts
that are trapped here yeah
so yeah i still like hill house more
however
it is one of those things that while
there's similarities and while they use
some of the
you know say music and such it's so
different that
it it's really easy for me to just look
at it at its own thing
and not really compare it and i'm not
just saying that to be you know like
pretentious cool reviewer
yeah it's i mean i am that uh i'm
talking
more in the sense of after the first
episode i wasn't even comparing it it
was like yeah
i could this is a very different show
yeah and i think that again i think
that's really smart well the thing i
i think helped me though is i read
enough little
opinions yeah that really prepped me for
that
whereas if i had just binged hill house
and then i went into this
i probably would have been taken aback
but i read enough people who were like
it's not scary it's more gothic romance
it's more drama
everyone was preparing my mindset for
that so i was able to go in and just
accept it i think that the ultimate
distinction for me is i think the first
that hill house is
perhaps a more like impressive season
because there's so much juggling and it
has such a nifty way of organizing its
events and
it has such an organizational structure
and there's that episode that's like all
one shot
whereas this one seemed like it toned
down some of that stuff it maybe
got a little out of your face in some of
the direction sides and in some of the
juggling it was trying to do and i
and i thought that made the experience
yeah just take on a different life and
pretty soon i too was not thinking about
hillary i
think though that this the the the voice
of this show
feels from a much earlier century
whereas hill house has a very modern day
sensibility so i think it's easier just
to connect and relate
whereas this has more of a novella vibe
to it you know
um but anyway thanks have to get that
out of the way because i know that's
what most people
have been doing online yeah yeah and
then louis as your patron asks us
how many of the easter egg ghosts did
you catch i caught a lot of them i think
i was literally always analyze the frame
looking for anything vaguely human
shaped
i caught i watched this with olivia and
she
caught so much like so much more than i
did
i caught a good amount around episode
six i think i
stopped looking because it became a
little
challenging to fully pay attention to
the show for me
when i'm so caught up in looking in the
background of things
and i'm as i'm like paying attention to
so many things at once now but
i did catch a we probably in total
caught around not a lot
um i wanna say
somewhere between 10 to 15 not a lot
that's the difference with this is
because i know for haunting of hill
house
people discovered that you know down the
road whereas here
sometimes it was a little bit more
obvious i felt i don't know if it's just
because i was actually
looking for it this time yeah that there
were times where i'm like well it's
clearly there look at it
it's like right there this would have
ruined doing reactions for the show
because i stopped looking because the
first three episodes watching this were
a lot of
who's that was that a
that's us staring into the screen too
hard never mind so yeah we did that
so many times especially the first three
episodes i felt like they were more
littered in the first four episodes
um and i'm sure they were there
throughout the rest of the season but
yeah around episode five or six
i i was i wasn't really looking for it
anymore
yeah i mean the funny thing is i went
into this season
and i knew about it during the first
season uh but i had much the same
experience this time where i had it in
my mind of like okay
because you know like this show you know
even with a slightly more restrained
directing style is very beautiful to
look at there's so many great shots to
drink
i actually didn't find that many on this
first watch
because i just kept getting sucked into
the show and being i think i kept having
that in the back of my mind is like
it's fun and i'm gonna keep my eyes
peeled but i'm not gonna try too hard
because i know that i'm gonna end up
rewinding every
10 minutes just to catch what i missed
while looking for stuff so
so yeah i feel kind of like a failure
because i didn't catch very many well
that's the thing is they know too so
they're getting clever at being like
here's a here's a big
wide shot have fun they would have more
fun with it in this sense sometimes i
remember like i think it was the
the first or second episode where danny
is
leaning over talking to flora outside
and then whenever it cut back to danny's
shot
sometimes the ghost would be there in
that same same exact frame
same shot cut to danny cut the floor cut
today get the floor and every other shot
of danny the ghost would be there in the
background sometimes obscured sometimes
more obvious and what i thought was fun
about doing it this time was the first
time i watched haunting a pill house i
uh the only time seeing haunted house i
never
spotted a ghost never did not even the
ones that were supposed to be there
right before yeah
not even the jump scares the blind manor
um what was fun about that was
uncovering what those shapes were um as
the show progressed
we were like oh that's the doctor right
there um
you know things like that the doctor
from the lady of the lake story
and how they like correspond to the
dolls yeah yeah
that was real that was the most fun part
to me was like putting those pieces
together and that's another thing about
the show that i think
they succeeded at too was setting up
their mysteries and questions and
letting the unraveling
happen uh i thought was always a blast
but thanks lewis the mha
uh asks us is this story a ghost story
or gothic romance to you
yes it's both it's uh it's undoubtedly
both
i think what you want to say is is it a
horror show
no not really it's like it's a weird
thing where
uh it's a ghost story in gothic romance
that feels a little bit detached from
being a full-on horror
show i think it's equally both because
they it's kind of cyclical
in the sense of ghost story and gothic
romance they definitely feed into each
other
from beginning to end right to its
closing shot and i love that approach
i don't really consider the first one a
gothic romance uh
it's super gothic but yeah the the
romantic elements are more
side quests than the point yeah whereas
this season seems to very much hone in
on romances of
like the stories being told at a wedding
you know i mean you have hannah and owen
story being told at the wedding
you have jamie and danny and peter and
uh miss jessel yeah rebecca yeah you
have that so you have all these
different
romantic stories that are and even the
lady of the lake yeah
yeah exactly her and her husband every
story was so tied into
gothic romance but it also bred ghosts
out of it the stories of not moving on
and grief it all tied in together
in a neatly wrapped package for me yeah
it's it's definitely
more i think it's equally both of these
yeah
and i think the issue that audiences are
having who are not liking it is it's not
it's not
a horror show i'm flashing right back to
crimson peak
which i mean crimson peak is more
overtly better show than crimson
yeah and i mean the thing is yeah i
agree the first season i think is very
goth
both of these seasons are very gothic in
their style their story telling the
traditions that they're pulling
from and this season i would just say is
full-on gothic romance
because gothic romance often just
includes a ghost story
it's it's the difference of what the
ghosts are for really and so yeah
whereas the first season a lot of the
ghost
activity is based in anguish and trauma
and it is the same so
here but with a more heartbroken an
element based in human attachments or
lack thereof
like so i feel like because love is at
the core of so much of this season i'd
say that this
one is yeah definitely gothic romance
whereas the first season i'd just say is
just
yeah a gothic ghost story yeah um but
because yeah i mean
the nature of so much gothic ghost
storytelling in the first place
is all about you know unrequited loves
and you know
unfinished business and despair and
people lingering you know it's it's all
about these broken relationships and
whatnot and so
you know it's very tonal and it's very
moody and i thought that you know again
that is
i feel like that is a legitimate avenue
of horror that doesn't get
respect or doesn't get considered horror
just because it doesn't rely as heavily
on in-your-face
ghoulish jump-scaring but really that
doesn't necessarily mean it's
not horror still because all the tones
are anguished tones fraught tones
it's a show painting in the kind of
horrors of life whether those be the
heartbreak variety or the murderous
variety yeah
absolutely riley burgess thank you for
the question is asking us
favorite love story of the season also
thoughts on the wedding scenes in the
final episode
that was fun to put together yeah in the
wedding scene
because i did have a thought by episode
5
or six where i was like wait a minute so
carla gagino just started telling the
story and how was she telling the story
she she like how confused are the people
listening
yeah like the amount of time jumping
that are happening
one and like i thought this was going to
be like a half hour most we've been
sitting here
at this party for the last well they
know it's getting busy with the traffic
right now we got to hit the road
and they acknowledged that and i
couldn't help but wonder when she said
like i told you it was a long story and
i'm like
do you mean like seven hours like like a
tv show like this
yeah or or was it like an hour in show
time but like what was your narrative
structure to tell in this and how do you
know
all of this that was probably one of the
confusing parts to me too
how do you know everything you know yeah
and
i mean to be fair and i'm not an expert
on the turning of the screw which this
is based on but i know that a big part
of that story's
you know legacy is the fact that the
narrator is you know you're wondering
are these things that
she might have witnessed or are these
just delusions of a
you know insane mind gone mad of trauma
you know or something like that
which again is a very gothic thing to do
i mean i like the reveal of knowing who
was at the wedding i thought that was
really fun yeah and also
like tying it back because it was it was
a bit of a bummer when you first learned
that like oh
flora and uh miles is it yeah smiles
uh they're forgetting what happened at
blind man or they're forgetting the
sacrifice that danny made
um which was a real like that was
heartbreaking
yes they get to live on and have happy
lives and get away from the
traumatic upbringing they had and i'm
like man but danny like if it's gonna
[ __ ] die because
she's like yeah man she's she like
possessed
sacrificed herself yeah so to have that
story
um you know be told to flora and and
miles for them to hear it again i
thought
was powerful and also it was fun just
seeing like
everyone who was there and it's like
final moments i thought was really great
it's kind of the summation of the whole
point of the show
well and carry them with us and that is
again another one of those things that i
think is very beautiful and
and pretty gothic as well as you come
out with this bitter sweetness of
it is i guess a happy ending that they
don't have to live with they don't have
to become the hill house family and live
with this drama dictating their life but
at the same time
in in a show about people's memories
being forgotten
partly and being manipulated and
distorted you know that is
heartbreaking for danny who is the
emotional core of
the entire season you know i if my
favorite love story
was easily you know rebecca and
and uh and peter oh rebecca and peter
yeah
yeah and peter for sure yeah because uh
peter
just seemed like such a good guy and
rebecca just seemed like such a smart
person
what is up with oliver jackson going
being horrible people lately
well you know he's such a horrible
person he got his redemption arc in the
first hill house season and that's about
enough of that
that was probably the scariest scene to
me when he was jealous after
owen gave oh god the battery i had to
try the bad
battering in my mouth he's gonna he's
gonna murder yeah
yeah i thought something yeah more
overtly savage would happen out of that
i thought they did a great job with his
character though because i hated
him and then you start to understand him
much
later in the season yeah when you he
keeps going through his little
time like he becomes like very
vulnerable and sensitive especially when
he's dead
yes like him as a ghost was much more
endearing
you feel much more pity for him yeah and
the way they handle that romance of like
trying to get him out of blind manor
i would like totally mess with rebecca
that whole thing with possessing her you
know you have that thought all right
i'm like oh he's gonna kill her isn't
he's gonna kill her while possessing her
this is so messed up
it's not my favorite i was joking about
that it's not my favorite
we don't really get a resolve on them do
we now that i think about it they're
they're the one we don't really get
resolution on
i guess they're just gonna get the hell
out of playground i guess they just
dissipate or they move on to the next
realm or or something yeah
uh i did yeah i really enjoyed the way
this season
did and that's the credit to the writing
of both of these seasons
is the amount of perspective you get to
see all around and yeah you find
yourself
understanding why everybody in the house
does not trust or like this person but
you also
see what she loves about him and yeah i
found that very compelling i think
in terms of the romances i think my
favorite one just personally would have
had to have been hannah yeah and owen
because you know they like they're such
lovely characters such lovely performers
you you
you know there's so much beauty and
sadness there that you just want it to
work
so so much in terms of just like my own
you know personal taste i think that's
the one for me but i also thought that
the jamie and danny the weight like
and and going back to season one hill
house like when she falls in love with
the doctor got like she
her love falling in or exceeded like
this
are just like she is so good at
following she's so good at falling in
love on screen like like yeah
like i really really was touched by all
of theirs
so you know i mean i don't want to spoil
an
upcoming answer for a few for a question
my personal favorite one because i i
agree i mean i was very much endeared by
the romance between hannah and owen
especially in the end of episode five
when she's realizing she's dead she's
like no i'll go to paris with you come
back
like that was heartbreaking yeah i went
to bed
heartbroken i had a terrible dream
that like shook me that felt like
something was being ripped out of me
because
uh hannah it was that that whole
storyline in episode five
it's funny how the season ones um
you know the bent neck lady was the
standout episode in most people's eyes
and i feel like episode five with hannah
is because i think that was also episode
five yeah and hannah's episode five is
also the standout for a lot of people
too you know yeah so they have there's
something about their episode fives
or they're like we gotta nail it this is
the one
right here this is the point people will
get to before they decide whether or not
to switch off or keep going yeah because
i was really endeared by that but the
one that was really
just bringing me you know an occasional
tear of joy
where i was so moved by the romance was
definitely a danny and jamie
it didn't seem obvious like once it
started getting close to the part where
that you know she puts her hand on her
and like wants to kiss her
yeah and jamie's like who would have
done good to know or whatever
that little line would have known you
know where that cute little line is like
a little bit before that it's not the
kind of thing
at least for me i wasn't watching it
going oh they're gonna hook up that's
totally they're setting up a total
romance between them
it was unexpected but felt natural that
it happened especially in the
the final episode where you're seeing
the life that they're
they get to have together i thought was
just absolutely
beautiful i was so touched by it uh and
there i forget
what moment it was that made me cry in
their
romance there was something or a few
like it was there
it was their romance that made me cry a
good amount of times i was so touched by
it especially like them learning to be
vulnerable with each other
they grow when they're together it's
like an empowering relationship it
really is
it's empowering because that's like a
relationship of
two individuals who grow as individuals
but are stronger as a unit the final
episode with them
as much exposition as there was as much
as they were like we gotta wrap this
[ __ ] up
yeah yeah we got a prologue to get
through
this whole episode just one big prologue
we gotta wrap
as much as there was a lot of that i
still found myself
incredibly moved and and my my like when
she finds
danny underwater and she's screaming
underwater you me us
you me us without whoops i i
i'm feeling it right now it was really
beautiful and i think that you know it's
like there
are lgbt aspects of the first season
that are a bit more
yeah easily from the outside viewed as
pulpy i think and
and this was an example of so much
hotter in the first season
but no i mean they're they're lesbian
love there is a certain amount of
and it's i think it's what i loved about
it too also
i got i have to sorry to cut you off
here i have to interrupt
i thought it was gonna be something with
danny they had hints in the flashback
later after you discover that she's into
jamie but when you're seeing the
flashback of the wedding dress and the
girl putting her hand
on her body okay so she's been attracted
a woman she's she's at least aware of
these feelings
yeah but i love how they didn't deal
with anything
of like i've never been with a girl like
there was nothing about
being gay that was a discussion yeah
i mean i'd be curious to hear some some
actual gay people's thoughts on it but
it seems it didn't feel exploitative at
all really did you know that gardner was
actually gonna be
oliver jackson cohen and then they
decided to cast
a woman and i think they just went with
the script oh cool
no that's what you do that is what you
do because it felt like a very natural
love story between two people that had a
lot of really really well performed
because so much of
the insecurity and the vulnerability is
just in little performance
ticks and little lines that don't seem
important but are very important
intentionally those little things of
like
it's okay like those little reminders
jamie gives because they just felt yeah
as a romance
i feel like you know again we just
watched the boys and you know like
there's a lesbian romance that is
discovered and then put like front and
center for everybody
and i feel like this show managed to
really imbue it with just
all the life and love that you know
resonates without being lurid about it
at all
you know yeah especially house of
victoria's like when she's drawn
uh danny is drawn to her she has that
like puppy dog
yeah yeah
that very like please please love me too
love me back i'll do anything i'm here
for you
i love you such a sweet voice but thank
you
and then we have to answer this question
coming from a man named eric
horstmann oh look out the man who's most
passionate about this
series it's not just a season the series
yeah we better get a third season
just like hill house the whole season
was amazing but some episodes stand out
which three episodes are your favorite
and why i
i think you pinned it i think you picked
my episode you picked
the episode
for me they were five eight and nine
though four and seven were so good too
maybe have to rethink this after
a second watch yeah undoubtedly five
five for sure yeah
five was like a sopranos and if you guys
haven't seen the surprise there's a lot
of dream
sequence episodes that was like a
sopranos like episode to me i feel like
most of us didn't know what was going on
yeah but we wanted to stick around with
this and find out
you know which is that's a great way to
hook an audience where you're like i'm
not i've been watching this for 40
minutes
i don't know what exactly is happening
yeah but i know i'm learning stuff
you know yeah and that's that's a very
hard thing to do and i really appreciate
this show for doing it both times but
especially this time getting me to a
point where i'm like
i i am pretty sure i'm lost but i think
i'm supposed to be so it's okay
i mean the thing with hannah though they
made it so obvious in the first
episode the first episode where she
doesn't eat or drink and because you're
coming off of hill house you're like oh
she's dead yeah
he's obviously dead something's up
sometimes the ghost rules are confusing
in this
season though uh admittedly okay so it's
intentional when they can appear is it
like hannah is able to remain because
she refuses to believe
she's dead so she's able to be present
with them but sometimes she seems like
she's touching them
because the other ghostly touched
someone and they take over their bodies
with her i'm trying to think of moments
where i'm like well they look like they
were physically interacting and there
was one scene
i i remember before that episode she's
drinking coffee and that's what was
throwing me off when i was like oh maybe
she's not dead because until that
moment where she's drinking coffee i was
thinking oh she might be alive
yeah but then when this episode started
i was like okay she's clearly dead and i
think we're going to find out why
and then you're seeing the well thing
and olivia's like oh she's down in the
well she's dead in the well you know
yeah um no the wall when she's at the
church yeah
you're uncovering the information like
the way that was crafted on a cinematic
directing
editing performance level everything
about that episode was undoubtedly the
highlight my second favorite episode is
eight where
you get the lady of the lake story that
was the one i was
kind of expecting to not be as
intrigued by but to me that was actually
the scariest one
you know because you're like there's
something really [ __ ] up about this
girl well yeah
and there's such a it's such a dis yes
it's a really distinct episode and even
though katie siegel is only in that one
really prominently she especially brings
just this sing like she's she's scary
yeah she's got this singularly driven
but also kind of
malevolent aura like she's so driven
that it almost comes off as like this
harsh
passion yeah and again it's it's a very
gothic thing and it's
yeah showing you the echoes of all this
and i love that they put it in black and
white
even the sister i thought was great like
yeah that was an unexpected turn like i
loved the
sometimes the narration was a little too
much in some of these episodes
but i actually really love the the
moment where the sister kills
uh katie siegel the lady of the lake
because
that whole thing about mercy and yeah
enough that was a great narration touch
and you're like oh yeah she's been a
[ __ ] for a long time
yeah and even though they shared the
same goal and drive it seems like some
kind of wedge has been driven that
cannot be alleviated yeah and then it's
like the sisters kind of
seems like she's kind of worse in the
end pertinent the sister i thought was
actually
like oh you're a kind of a worse per
like she started off as a better person
and it seems like the circumstances and
the situations
devolved her yeah and ruined her morale
yeah and she became worse in the end of
sister
yeah and it put her into this place of
anguish
brought on by yeah like the guilt
there's this weird thing of like i
needed some release but also now i'm
just gonna be tormented until i die
i think what's great about episode 8 is
that it's the only one you could
it's kind of like its own short film
um that's put into this season yeah
because
you're not cutting in and out of present
time they hop you into that time you're
just there
until that story is complete so it's
like this own isolated episode that also
explains the majority of this season
it shows you why all this was possible
and i think that episode kind of
is to yeah solidify what i guess i don't
feel like rules is exactly the right
word here but it does kind of solidify
the nature of the haunting and i like
that they went with a different
nature than hill house and i mean
obviously that probably comes
with the source material but yeah just
having it seemed
to me just you know from what i know
about ghost
stories from hearing so many over the
years is that that is one of those
you know ideas in the lore is that you
know somebody just
wills themselves will not let go to the
point that their
energy just because it like calcifies
and just becomes this
presence that infects a place and then
you know that's where so many ghost
stories come from and i thought they
realized that really well and then used
that forward yeah creating this gravity
well i thought was a great
uh metaphor you know yeah i actually
have to say episode seven that's the one
where
uh danny's tied up your alert and then
the kids are interacting with uh rebecca
and peter and like that episode to me
was
that was the most tense episode nine i
was the most moved by
but i really did think it was it felt it
was starting to feel rushed
a good portion of it i was moved to
tears in that one
and i was very much touched by the like
i really loved actually i love
nine but i really see it's flaws whereas
episode seven for me
was the one that i thought was this is
not scary but it's certainly intense
like i
i'm i'm very much like what's gonna
happen especially with uh
the desperation on everyone in that in
that uh whole
scene you know it's little reservoir
dogs
attic scene you know it's funny that
certain episodes that take
side characters who have a very distinct
presence because of whatever perspective
we've seen up until this point yeah they
take the focus of an episode and then
become a whole other experience for you
because yeah watching as
uh peter and rebecca try and figure this
out and watching the hurt and betrayal
that comes out
through rebecca because of what peter is
desperately doing and i love those beats
about you know like no one should ever
ask for this much help
you know you you see again these lost
souls and and yeah i thought that was
the most challenging
because it even does make you sympath
like the whole thing with uh peter's
hell and everything i thought was great
too because it's you know it's again
showing just all the layers of anguish
that contribute to this yeah
and i love the touch too of how rebecca
does not inhabit
flora because rebecca i surprised we
haven't made one perfectly splendid joke
this whole time
because when rebecca was about to
inhabit uh flora
on a personal level i was thinking
come on man haven't you been manipulated
by this guy
enough you're dead because of him yeah
like
gave me a break you're really gonna get
into this
and then to have that revealed oh thank
you
but now she's grown and now she's moved
past
uh peter patrick i keep peter just
reminds a bit of a bateman vibe i guess
yeah yeah yeah everyone's motivations
and everything just started clicking in
a real natural way
little subtle moments like do you want
to end up like her and he pulls
uh perdida's the body forward and it's
like faceless like everyone's
motivations and the whole
purpose of it all just started making a
lot of sense
the dream sequence stuff i think might
confuse people like like
living down when we were watching we're
kind of going back and forth so i was
under the impression that when the
ghosts inhabit the body of a living
person the living person gets trapped in
their own memories and subconscious
yeah they kind of bump you in there
while they take the wheel for as long as
they can
and then the living person learns to
dream hop so i think some people might
have thought like flora and miles were
dead
so i think this was might be confusing
people and then like i said some of the
rules with hannah were a little
confusing i like the
the way they handle the dream sequence
stuff how it's always they're all unless
it's like they're repeating the same
memory again
usually when they're thrown back in the
memory they're reliving it and then it
takes them a moment to realize like oh
wait a minute wait we've done this
before yeah
i'm supposed to be five years old what's
going on here
yeah and i mean that stuff is confusing
and i think for good reason partly
because confusing things are unsettling
but i did ultimately not have too much
of an issue partly because with
hannah that's another one of those again
gothic things
it's almost similar uh to the lady of
the lake in a way
she's so concerned with and dedicated to
upkeeping this place that she sort of
bonded her soul here as
you know helped along by the gravity
well that is bligh manor at least in
that sense there were moments where they
would also uh acknowledge
the pass-through versus the you know
concrete
touch-ability of the ghosts and i feel
like perhaps there's not really anything
explained but it seemed like
there is kind of different levels of
corporeality if that makes any sense
like sometimes they're walking through
each other but it seems like sometimes
the ghosts when concentrated enough or
in the right situation can actually
interact with things yeah
so just having those ideas in the back
of my head made it
easier not to get too hung up on those
things and yeah as for
the lore in general it's often said and
they even touch on it in the show the
children
have just a different ability to
perceive these things they're not you
know as
sculpted and blinded by you know all the
various aspects of
growing up um so you know that's another
gothic trope that i think
works you know it's because kids are you
know tricky to understand sometimes and
uh yeah i
kind of took it as that if someone's
being possessed they are pushed into a
memory
you know until they are kind of jumped
back in for whatever reason whether that
be the connection
you know fading or whatever i kind of
came to view
you know the because of insidious now
like astral travel astral projection the
astral plane
is more of a well-known concept so i
feel like because
dreams are said to exist there and
ghosts and spirits and whatnot kind of
interface with or or occupy that plane
it sort of made sense to me that perhaps
yeah these echoes of people's souls
that are littered all over this manner
you know if you're
in some kind of dream state and you know
how to access the astral plane in some
way shape or form like these children
do yeah you know it ultimately kind of
came together
in this casserole of like i buy this you
know like this
for the for even though it doesn't do
like a specific rules dump and i can
certainly see why people would find it
just confusing to the point of being
frustrating
with all these gothic themes in play i
thought it worked pretty well for for me
yeah and i thought it tied itself
together pretty well in in those
respects
and i mean also too the first episode
came up in the second miles there were a
couple things miles did
where i was just sitting there going
he's got to be possessed by like an
older man there's there's no way
like there's got to be some possession
element and i like that they unpack that
a little too as opposed to the first
yeah these are possession elements cool
because he's not like fully possessed
yeah it's not demons yeah it's like he
can hop in and out so sometimes he's
miles and sometimes he's not so
yeah i think that makes for uh even more
tricky mystery to unpack
let's move on to uh the last
question we have for today i mean i know
we've had a few more
but you know we're getting long
yeah get along the last question uh this
one comes again from horror and gamer
full circle here hey uh he actually had
his question stacked
and then uh this one to me i thought
would be a good chance just talk about
the cast
he said who stood out the most my
personal favorite from the ones who
stood out the most would have to be
for me personally it was whoever played
hannah tania
miller i see your name right here tania
miller her and actually owen
both of them were the ones that they
would have the most you really i
really like the new players jamie like
those three were the ones who actually
left me with the biggest
impact greg sestero from the room yeah
great in those couple scenes of the
wedding they all brought so much depth
but hannah had this strange
aura of politeness yet you know like
longing for
more but reserved and very
caring but wears her heart on her sleeve
but also
can be shy she also felt very strong
like i thought she might be the hero of
the show by the time we got there
actually wasn't expecting danny to be
the ultimate hero
owen was just committed just so
unbelievably charming and sympathetic
and witty and witty funny you know
yeah and uh jamie you know kind of has
that like sarcastic repressed tough girl
edge to her
they were the ones who really stood out
to me a lot like the new players
especially i thought everyone's great
though to make it very blunt everyone is
great you know victoria pedretti as
as uh it's danny dude like man this girl
can act like from oh my goodness
hill house here like transformation very
different characters oliver jackson
cohen i feel like that's where you and i
kind of have slight i think his
performance is
solid yeah i was distracted by his
accent it just did it
didn't sound not that i hang out with
like scottish people who have been to
scotland but there's something about his
voice i'm like this doesn't sound
i don't i don't feel like this is your
real voice and then i was thinking
i've never heard interviews with the guy
this might be his real voice but it
doesn't sound like his real but then i'm
like oh he's actually british when i
yeah after i finished watching the show
i had to find out yeah but you said you
accented him that was the most one of
the
few things john i talked about like
you're the action for him didn't bother
you
no i i'd be very curious as to what
people over the pond have to say about
this because there are
a lot of americans doing various uk
accents and there are also you know
actors from the uk doing other accents
so i gotta imagine if you're british
maybe some of these are
a little hard to listen to but i
actually thought that generally speaking
the accent work was pretty good across
the board at least for the people who i
know
aren't uh of that native accent oliver
jackson cones i really started to buy
when he was a goat for some reason
around that point
the voice was no longer distraction when
he's breaking down and he's not putting
the charm on
so much and he's kind of in a more
vulnerable state yeah there's something
about the voice then that felt
more natural to me and i feel like i'm
probably
way in the minority on that uh when it
comes to him i accept that
okay it's my opinion carla gagino had a
very fascinating accent i thought carlo
gagino's narration was good
yeah i think she was a little
distracting in voice at first
then i'm like well but i'm kind of it
kind of fits with the tone of what i
hear this show is going for so it was
easy for me to latch on to but then when
you find out who she
is it was a bit of a how i met your
mother situation for me
see i was sitting there evolving
that's fair that's a fair i think they
don't seem to resemble each other
in any way not not just in terms of
physical appearance but
everything about the way carlo gajito
talks and
carries herself i get that jamie the
character will have grown
and from all the materials all these
things
yet i couldn't really see the
the the connection i couldn't see that
invisible line
that yeah that makes them tied together
yeah i i'll give you that and i mean and
it didn't bother me
as much with the kids and whatnot but
there were moments where especially
later on with miles i was like he's
doing a good like adult
male but he doesn't really seem like the
exact same character as peter
or something like that and not that you
know it's the same concept
but but i can see where you're coming
from it didn't bother me so much
but i think that's a fair criticism
because you know
jamie is such a you know such a specific
character by the time you get to the end
carla gugino's version seems like so
proper yeah
yeah and like you might get the sense
that she's probably born into wealth or
something right like that's
kind of the way she comes across jamie's
like you know rough around the edges
tough sharpshooter you know the only
thing i can say is maybe it's because
of the where she is and the fact that
she knows some of these people or the
people she's talking about
maybe there's like a reserve there again
being that you only see
carla gugino twice at the very beginning
and very end
uh after an episode that does the most
of just watching
jamie and danny grow together you know i
i can see why that would be distracting
a bit
uh henry thomas as henry wingrave
i gotta say man it goes way past gt
first
ut [ __ ] man this guy's trying to get out
of the e.t
image for so long now really good
now he's he's great he is awesome in
this
you get the exact opposite effect where
i thought if you tell me on paper
if like oliver jackson's calling him or
doing accents
i'm more likely to believe i'll
instantly buy oliver jackson cohen
thomas but henry thomas really seems
like a british dude
yeah that was i kept i kept going in and
these days you know i've just become
uh conditioned to be a little wary of oh
we got a lot of accents going
let's see how this goes but yeah more
often than not i found myself being like
this is pretty good
he seems like a stately rich british guy
yeah
and uh learning his backstory was
um man everyone's just so messed up in
this show
everyone's messed up they're all messed
up people well that's the thing
i think those are the keys to gothic
horrors it's all about these sides of
life these sort of traumatic
uh emotional experiences that linger and
haunt you know well what i think like
his performance i think is a good
representation of kind of what the show
does
as a whole is you present the surface
whether it be something that
is instantly immediate like up for the
first thought it's like scary or
this person's an [ __ ] this person's
bad and then you pull back the curtain
and you start
unraveling why they are the way they are
and why
whose perspective made you think a
certain way about them
at first or whatever yeah and i think
with henry thomas's portrayal that
especially comes hand in hand i actually
really liked his performance as the
alter ego of himself too
that's perfect that perfect smile that
you know like you could just imagine an
interview with henry thomas if
like i really had to think about the
smile yeah
did you really feel that actor choice
with that yeah i spent hours in front of
the mirror smiling
but that was fun to watch and the and
the birth of that uh
alter ego i thought was powerful i mean
at first you're dealing with ghosts now
you're dealing with like
schizophrenia yeah and i mean it's that
yeah you're dealing with
personifications
various degrees and i think that's more
of a stretch in terms of rules like i
could see that actually confusing people
because that is just
a you know aspect of himself that was
created
out of a certain series of traumas but
how was he able to come back to life at
the end
oh he was his neck was snapped wasn't he
or suffocated he was still he was being
suffocated and i think she just didn't
do all the way
but he was a ghost at one point uh was
he a ghost yeah he was definitely he was
certainly a good he was definitely dead
or was it like the that mark ruffalo
reese witherspoon movie where he's like
he's somewhere between death and
and it could be that it could be that
his soul he's not fully dead
his soul is in is in limbo right now
it's sort of got one foot in his body
yeah clinging
i'd have to go back in and re-watch that
sequence again he was for sure dead
because
when he was a ghost and he was looking
at his body i was like oh is he gonna
he's gonna save the day because he just
showed up here at the right time oh i
thought that was just the alter ego just
kind of looking on and lingering with
him oh really
i thought that was the alter ego damn
the rules
it didn't make that clear because
they've had stuff where everyone dies
and they see their dead body
so that's what i thought we were looking
at where someone died no no
because you might be right because
hannah as a ghost ends up talking
with the with henry the ghost saying
like
tell owen something something i forget
what she says
and then and then henry comes back okay
i'm going to go re-watch it
last night but there are two of him
and there have been two of them the
whole time and
hannah clearly is a ghost that can
interact with anybody
so i was like i don't know maybe yeah
but if he was knocked out and there's
there
there are three henry's there were there
were three henrys all right then i'm
gonna go back i thought it was the alter
ego but that was
maybe my misreading of the situation and
then uh you have
like the kids are great um yeah they
felt like real kids
yeah and i thought it was very handy the
way they did the possession thing to to
alleviate these certain moments where
you know
you're always gonna run into like kids
not talking like kids
and i thought that that made it feel
more natural but the one who i feel like
flora probably has like the highlight
lines especially that perfectly splendid
thing she is great she's very charming
uh but miles in particular
i thought you know having this like
child who's grieving and then having to
sort of bounce back and forth between
being possessed and when not possessed
and especially when he is possessed like
the seventh episode he doesn't seem like
a kid playing an adult
i'm like no he seems like there's a he's
an adult yeah
exactly he's just carrie that was why so
many of his interactions with danny are
so uns
unnerving because i was like just a kid
should not do that yeah yeah
you know and i loved i like there were
times where i was like ah man i hate
this kid
it's really easy to hate not not like
he's doing a bad job but just like i'm
really creeped out but i thought the
more they showed you the other side
especially once they made it very clear
what was happening he did feel
like a different kid when he was just
miles
and especially when he's arguing with
peter about like this doesn't feel right
like why are we doing this i don't like
it those were the moments where i really
especially started to appreciate
what that kid was doing yeah yeah you
know oh yeah gosh alex esso i met her
one time um
at jason dolan's movie the vanishing of
citizens
out now stream it she's there uh there
is a very nice person
and then uh you've worked with her once
sometimes
yeah some little like fangoria type
things yeah yeah so we don't really like
know where we're gonna like talk to her
on the regular or something like that
you know you know we were we're
instagram friends yeah that's as far as
our
definition of a friend i could remind
her where we've met before yeah
she's in doctor sleep and and then she
she's back here
in this role as charlotte wingrave the
you know the the one who's sleeping with
henry i remember when i met her
i wasn't aware of starry eyes or all her
other horror movies that she's done
where she's actually like
remember like people were kind of coming
up to her and i had no idea who she was
and i remembered like just talking to
her again because i'm like oh we're
standing in the same circle i was like
oh where are you from she's like oh
canada i'm like oh that's cool
and i'm like sorry worked on anything so
far she's like yeah i've done a couple
of movies and stuff like she's very just
nonchalant about it
i'm like that's crazy she just come from
here in canada you start like making
work that's awesome hopefully i'll be
able to find out like oh she's got like
she's got
she's hooked up throwing reputation she
is on top
she got that mike flanagan uh calling
card when she first
pops into the show she is just you know
charlotte went grave as his very
traditional proper english woman uh
persona right
very bright but then uh she has another
layer in the story of tragic romance
where she's having an affair in her
fair in some ways you know it's like
it's not right but it also
kind of makes sense how it happened it's
sickening that it's with the brother
her scene where she is the truth is
coming out
with her husband i thought was very very
powerful very limited dialogue you could
feel this
conflict within like more than just the
tears that she's having at the dinner
table
about how she's like trying to avoid the
conversation by keeping her
attention focused on the fridge yeah
yeah she just won't turn around she's
trying to
focus on other things to talk about with
like that feeling of
she knows that he knows and she's trying
to avoid it just to be in denial of the
situation
and then when she has to go to henry
those scenes i thought were very
powerful like everyone here is
is amazing especially greg cistero like
this everyone here is
top-notch well even the way they just
draw that contrast like that scene you
know that he understands
and the very next scene when he's
talking to his brother and like the rage
and hatred like it was a perfect two
sides of a coin because with
your wife you know like there's i was a
part of it like i was gone like there
was parts of this that i brought on
myself but also
my relationship with my brothers was
ruined forever yeah exactly and it was
yeah a great array of nuances
i love the kind of ambiguous ending that
they have with henry and flora
because you know that's that's his
daughter biologically speaking
yeah but it doesn't seem like he'll ever
get to the point where he will admit
that
mm-hmm out of respect but he'll still
get a chance to raise her
you know it'd be a part of her life yeah
i think that was a nice that was a
really great touch
so yeah everyone's great the only things
i have most of my complaints are kind of
chalked up into the first four episodes
of
if just sometimes the horror felt a
little bit tacked on
and like we need to have some scary
stuff we could actually
make people jump i had the i had the
feeling they really
didn't care about to do some of the
horror but it was
it was kind of pushed in there because
they have to
i don't know if that's true or not
that's the way it read
and uh the final episode was a little
bit
too much of a let's hold the problem
yeah
but but within that there was still so
much to love and so
yeah you know so yeah that's pretty much
my only complaints
about it every everything else i'm not
perturbed by the whole it's not a scary
debuggle no and again i i i really wish
that the god that this type of horror
that gothic horror and gothic romances
would be more embraced within
like it's a legitimate type of horror
like horror doesn't have to be
aggressive bloody and scary it can
sometimes just be chilling
and sombra like it horror i think
explores the more anguished emotions of
life and there are a lot of those other
than
anger and you know flight so yeah i
think that
uh it's not really a problem at all to
me i think this is perfect for this time
of year it's a beautifully
told beautifully rendered and
wonderfully gothic story and uh yeah
highly recommend all right guys well i
think you'd ever want to submit it
questions it's a show so we kind of go
forever
yeah we could talk about all this some
more in-depth ones but you know we
didn't even do a non-spoiler for this
but thank you guys for the questions
that you submitted wish we could do
everyone's but
i kind of choose the questions that will
allow us to sort of talk about
most people's questions choose the
questions from people who are the better
people
no you know what i mean because there's
there's so many questions and sometimes
they're more specific when i'm like but
by
answering this general question i'll
probably answer that more specific
question
yeah exactly hopefully we covered
everything trying to discover what
everyone wants us to talk about yes
that's right thank you guys so much for
being here this was fun uh what do you
think about the haunting of blind man or
how do you think it compares to hill
house
is there one that you prefer let us know
down below subscribe click the
notification bell last on all these
eric horstmann eric saved you for this
one buddy
the one saved you for this one you have
been begging us to cover this show
and now here we are here we are covering
it main reason
for you that's this is not even a lie
no one else watches this but you will
have done our job
we put out devil all the time questions
and suddenly just
gonna take a long time to sort through
all these questions are eric with
different accounts
there's a few questions it's pretty
simple to organize but we still got an
hour out of it but i love you buddy
you're a wonderful person to talk to man
uh getting to talk to you the other day
for an extended period of time was
actually like
hey i really feel like i'm we could have
a real friendship
in like outside of just internet
connection if we ever lived in the same
area or whenever we do see each other in
person i feel like would have
a grand old time and have a lot of
laughs and share a lot
of the same philosophical beliefs on
society and such
so buddy i love you i hope you're being
safe
enjoy the next 12 re-watches of hani
complied matter
yeah man and if you want to come possess
my body you're welcome any time oh
that's the haunting i want the haunting
of john humphrey by eric horstmann
anyway buddy thank you so much for being
here
you